You are listening to radiolab radiolab
from [inaudible], w.
N. Y. S. T. E. N. N. P. E. R.
Okay. I got to see, I'm
suddenly regretting this.
I was looking forward to
this all day, but now it's,
I didn't expect it to be so
profoundly dark. You're scared.
I was a little tiny bit. Yeah. Ah Dude,
you don't need to be doing that at like
a moron just turned his lights off.
It's a free here. We do that when
you're driving out in the book.
So that's a producer, Pat Walters and I.
This is kind of one is this one right
here. This is the rumor crossroads.
And I say we are here, so
a pad, and I know it's,
I know it's you and you're driving
in the dark. Yes. It takes me set up.
So a little while back, pat
and I went down to Clarksdale,
Mississippi to this little
tiny town out in the sticks,
Mississippi Delta drove down
this dirt road and this was dark.
I mean curtain of black dark till we
got to this place where our little road
crossed, another little road
made kind of an x tape recorder.
Should we get out of the car? Yeah.
And we got out of the
car and we stood there,
Kayla to be completely silent
and waiting five minutes to midnight
because we were told if we stood in that
very spot til midnight, the devil
would come and uh, talk to us.
What was that over there? Stop it.
I'm going to beat you at this. Make Fun.
You do that one more time. Why? Why?
I should wait and find out,
I guess. No, you should ask.
Would you like to know why we
were waiting for the devil?
Yes. A bunch of tool bags. We are.
Okay. So I've been interested for years
in this story of Robert Johnson and the
crossroads. I mean, do you
know him? Robert Johnson,
one of the Great Blues Musicians of
all times, influenced a ton of people.
Eric Clapton led Zepplin. He's
also the center of this mill.
Situate me in time. When did Robert
Johnson live? So here's the story. Yeah,
1920s Robert Johnson is
a kid in Mississippi.
[inaudible] wants to play the blues
hanging around blues guys, but he sucks.
Other blues guys would laugh
at him. So he goes away,
disappears one day shortly after,
comes back and he's not just
good now. He's incredible.
I mean he's making this music
that's not just technically good,
but it's just got a feeling
to it that's so different.
And are the other musicians like
a Umay were like what happened?
And supposedly what he
says to them is, well,
one night I walked out into the darkness,
found a place where two roads cross
and I waited there till midnight,
waited at a place and
they're going to wait to,
there's lots of apparently what you
do when you want to meet the devil,
you walk out of town, find the
crossroads at precisely midnight.
The devil come up, he'll take your guitar,
he'll tune it, hand it back to you,
and in that moment you've given the
devil your soul and he has given you the
ability to play anything
is that story is still told, oh my God,
this is like one of the most famous
like eh myths in rock and roll.
This is a story that's
repeated constantly.
I mean it's like one of the
most enduring stories in music.
I was just testing it and for some
reason, for the last 12 years or so,
I keep thinking about it and
I'm always like, one day,
one day Radiolab is going to
go down to the crossroads.
We're going to figure out where
this damn story came from.
And this is an honest question,
but is there something about
the myth that is true? Yeah,
something like that. We've
seen so many stars though. No,
this is amazing. It's beautiful.
All right, so what do you do?
We didn't see any devil first of all
really, but oh my God, a shooting star.
We did see a shooting star
and so we ended up there. We ended
up, started doing a lot of reporting,
you know, going around Memphis, visiting
Clarksdale, all these different places.
And the funny thing, the
very first thing that we,
that we sort of learned about
this whole story and uh,
we learned about it from this guy and,
uh, Tom Graves who lives in Memphis,
who studied the history,
very first thing we learned is it
actually the myth in a way began here.
We didn't even have to go to
Memphis. He began right here. Here.
What do you mean? In New York City? Yeah.
What do you mean starts in New York?
Well,
it starts on a very particular day in
a very particular place and time with a
very particular guy.
I think we can trace pretty much this
whole thing back to John Hammond,
you know, at Columbia records. I mean,
he's the one that sort of pushed the
whole thing into two to everybody.
And John Hammond, uh, was an
interesting guy. He was, uh,
one of the heirs to the Vanderbilt
fortune, you know, in New York.
He was a thorough New Yorker and it CBS,
he was a sort of a talent
scout and John Hammond had,
this is Elijah Walden historian. He
had the best years in show business.
Pretty much ever. You
discovered so much talent. God,
Billie Holiday Count
Basey Aretha Franklin,
Bob Dylan, Stevie wave von
[inaudible]. He discovered
Bruce Springsteen.
I mean the idea that that the same guy
could discover Bruce Springsteen and cow
basey. It's crazy here.
Any of the moment that we're interested
in happened kind of early in John
Hammond's career. He was very young.
He was in his twenties doing well
cause he'd already brought on,
I think it was Danny Goodman,
who was a huge success.
This would be the late thirties Benny
Goodman has the first major integrated
band and John Hammond.
He thought that racial
segregation was an abomination.
And right around the time
the Benny Goodman broke,
he decided it's time to
make a statement. So yeah,
in 1938 John Hammond decided
to put together this one
concert that would be like
the whole history of
black music from the old
hey
slave era spirituals
up to the hottest swing.
And not only was it going to cram the
entire history of black music into one
concert, you wanted to
put it in Carnegie Hall
as an
yeah,
that Carnegie Hall, they're good.
It's a very high tone place.
It's Carnegie Hall. You
know, what was it called?
It was called from spirituals to
swing from spirituals to swing.
But here's the problem and this whole
chronology, he was putting together,
he needed somebody to
represent backwoods blues.
He didn't have anybody. Uh, so,
so he sends one of his guys
down to Mississippi to a
particularly famous record
shop,
and the guy comes back with a record
from this young guy named Robert Johnson.
Was he known at that point? No, he
was a nobody. He was a nobody. Well,
when he heard this record, John Hammond
thought, wow, this is the best of the
Backwood blues guys I've ever heard.
That sort of haunting voice.
He knew right away. This was the guy,
I'm gonna pluck him from ops security
and I'm gonna put him in Carnegie Hall.
And so he sent word
down to Mississippi to,
to try to get Robert
Johnson and bring him up.
Word came back that Robert
Johnson had had died,
just died very, very recently.
Just a few months before he was messing
around with a woman and the woman's
husband gave him a bottle of
poisoned whiskey and that was it.
Wow. Well there's a blue thing. His
death. Yeah. So He's out of the program.
One would think concert rules around
December 13th, 1938 here we go.
This was a concert. If you could have
been there, you want it to be there.
And John Hammond is the MC
tonight. We are glad to
have and he, you know,
walks the crowd through the chronology,
starting with this spiritual
on the Boogie Woogie,
Benny Goodman and to count Basey Orchestra
and he gets that many tails. Well,
the big surprise of the,
this is what he said,
although unfortunately
this part was not recorded,
was to bring you this guy that I
discovered recently, Robert Johnson.
And we just found out that he died,
but I still want you to hearing and
we're going to play a couple of his best
songs. How did he play it?
He played it on a phonograph record
and Mike it through the PA system right
there on right there on stage
drops a needle and he played,
one of them was preaching blues,
which happens to be maybe my favorite
[inaudible]
and you can just imagine these
spell ballot people in this audience
[inaudible]
hearing a record being
played through the PA
[inaudible]
it was very obvious. Something different.
I mean what a remarkable thing and that
was in a sense Robert Johnson's Angus.
Not in a sense it was his
introduction. It was his debut.
It's so ghostly. Yeah.
What's most obvious is his absence.
Now at this point there is no myth
about a devil in the crossroads.
All you got is music sung by
a guy who's not in the room.
When the record finishes,
did they sit quietly or do they jump
up and down and yell or that we have no
idea. I mean, it wasn't recorded,
but temptation would be to
say their minds were blown.
But probably what happened was it, they
just clapped politely in the concert,
kept going.
[inaudible] but the seed was planted and
that seed would bloom in the weirdest
way 22 years later. So let me
just fast forward a bit. Okay.
See from 1938 to about 1916
threes because before no one,
I really listened to Robert Johnson,
not too many of his records were
in circulation cause you know,
it was the war years and people were
really into these like twists and pop kind
of happy records. But then
as you slide into the 60s,
people get kind of tired of that stuff
and they started getting into folk music.
Awesome man. I bet it baby Mama
Kingston trio and all that.
Kingston trio, Pete Seeger, all of
these guys are both man. So, um,
John Hammond again, John Hammond,
he had his finger on the
pulse of what was going on.
He knew he had just signed Bob Dylan
[inaudible]
my baby's dog. Dylan's first
record as you can hear,
was kind of Bluesy in place.
So Hammond thought, hmm,
maybe now is the time to revisit
the whole Robert Johnson thing.
Maybe put out a Robert
Johnson record. So we did.
And then people took those records
overseas and then guys like Eric Clapton
heard it flipped out.
Started recording covers
[inaudible]
mean it just sort of like I
went into work drive. Yeah.
Yeah.
This is the really the
song that catapulted Robert
Johnson into the world time.
It's still, despite the name of the
song, there was no sailing of any souls.
Crossroads is a metaphor you use in
countless blues songs come to the
crossroads. Which way are you going to go?
Just refers to a decision point that
shouldn't surprise anybody. So if you,
if you bought the vinyl album and
you looked at the album cover,
there's no on the back
cover, no, no devil myth yet.
But now all the conditions are sort of
in place because you've got this whole
folk roots movement when people who want
to know more about the music and you've
got a guy in Robert Johnson who's
being covered by huge rock bands,
but who nobody knows
the first thing about.
So you have this void that needed
to be filled and into that space.
Walks a guy named [inaudible].
No, his name's not pat. Pat.
You take this part. All right,
so moment when January we're in Memphis,
we went to see this guy who was one of
the first people to find out anything
about Robert Johnson. In a way.
He's actually at the root of
the myth about Robert Johnson.
So he assaulted the devil, don't
we? Didn't mean to be right.
His name's Dave David Evans,
professor of music at the University of
Memphis. He works in the music building.
So as you walk in and you're like 60
different instruments playing and you kind
of feel like you're losing your mind,
but when you step into his office, okay,
thanks for having us.
It's Kinda quiet.
She felt weirdly appropriate because
we're surrounded by all of these old books
and stacks of reel to reel tapes of the
people that he's interviewed over the
last five decades. And
while we were there,
he told us about one of
those taped interviews,
particularly the changed everything.
I was a student at UCLA.
This is 1966 just getting
interested in folk music and blues.
Got a guitar or you know, even
started gigging around a little bit.
I was interested in Tommy Johnson.
Now Tommy Johnson is a
pretty famous blues guy, gay,
but there's no relation between
Tommy Johnson and Robert Johnson.
None whatsoever. And musically
they're way different.
Tommy Johnson yodels AIG gave
[inaudible].
Yeah, Robert Johnson doesn't do that. No.
So David Evans was into Tommy Johnson.
I hadn't met, uh,
I had heard a number of his
recordings and admit Babe Stovall,
the sidecar
blues singer who was
on the circuit at 1964.
And a babe had known Tommy and
he told Dave, well, you know,
if you want to find Tommy Tommy's dead,
but I can point you to his brother.
Ladelle Johnson. Well, he was
living in a little house in Jackson,
Mississippi and uh, Dave decides
to go see him. No, Tommy,
I'm recording the interview. See if you
could learn a few things about Tonya.
And 1914 dash 40 came back,
Ladell was a blues man turn
preacher of the visionary.
Spry didn't play the blues anymore,
but he sang for David A. Little bit.
Hey, why don't you, yeah,
my longterm cry.
Hey Baby, don't you? Yeah,
my lawns and [inaudible]
you treat me Mama.
[inaudible] you do. When did
you first start singing? It's
amazing interview to listen to many case
after he sang a little bit David car
and he played a bit.
Oh [inaudible]
[inaudible]
and after that Madell tells Davis story
about his brother Tommy. And again,
this is Tommy Johnson, not Robert Johnson,
but Adele tells Davis story that tries
to explain how his brother Tommy got so
good. And to our knowledge, this
tape has never been broadcast before.
You could say again, it kind of
tangle up song. You long doing,
I bet you he would play.
Me and him would praise for some white
folks here and he'd just get shut up.
And yesterday,
Dan farmer ready buck
and he could make a song.
He could make a song in 10
minutes and I'd ask him,
now you have dome we're live in. You
did not. She and go. Only that man,
my wife day, he said him.
The reason he knows so much.
He show himself to the
devil. I asked him how
he said,
if you want to learn how to play anything
you want or you play at Norlane at a
Mitch Song,
your Shell that you take your guitar
and you go who are room Croson dad or we
go across roadie and said get
there. Be sure to get there.
Yes. The Litter for 12 o'clock that
night, Joe, you will know you are beat in
and jail. You have,
you get door and be playing a
piece sitting there by yourself.
Say you have to go by yourself and be
sitting there playing a piece and jail,
big black man will walk up there and
take your car and he attuning and then he
play a piece and hand it back.
Dude said that's the way I learned
how to play anything I want.
And he could not. He told that didn't
bring in anything, don't care what is
strong?
No,
I mean I was clocking stuff on
Tommy Johnson and here was uh,
this legend, uh,
Dave says he wasn't quite sure
what to make of this. I mean,
he knew that the idea that the person
could sell their soul to the devil in
exchange for limitless talent. That is
a very old myth. But that was about it.
So he goes back to UCLA and one night
he's chatting with some friends, you know,
Grad students have their
bull sessions. You know,
we all talked about these things where,
and he tells his friends about this
thing that Ladelle had said about Tommy.
And in the room that day was a fellow
Grad student named Pete Welding.
Pete was as much of a
blues freak as I was.
And according to David, as
Pete listening to this story,
he makes a little mental switcheroo.
He thinks to himself, you know,
this whole soldier soul to the devil thing
would make a hell of a lot more sense
if it's about Robert Johnson, not
Tommy Johnson, Robert Johnson.
I mean,
the fact is Robert Johnson sang a
song about going to a crossroads
[inaudible].
Now he doesn't in the song,
he doesn't say that he went
there to meet the devil,
but he also sang another song
on the same album, uh, about me.
And the devil walking side by side
bed, bathroom, you
know, which does suggest
at least in the song, he's
in some kind of [inaudible]
partnership with the [inaudible].
So Pete has this thought that this
story sounds a lot more Robert Johnson,
he than Tommy downs need.
And a few months later he travels to
Mississippi and he ends up interviewing
this really famous blues
man named Sun House.
Oh Jim Myron [inaudible] in your fee,
Pete asks son about Robert Johnson.
Son Tells Pete the usual story about
how Robert Johnson was just so bad.
Get up on stage. Yes. Just
as in the people you know
[inaudible] I know Josh [inaudible]
boy put them. Give that thing.
Not a running us crazy.
That's a little bit of Stone
House that we found on Youtube.
So son tells Pete that story
and it unusual way says
Robert Johnson disappeared.
He came back, he was better than
all of us. Nobody knew how I did it.
And then probably what happens
is David is in that moment,
I think Pete asked a leading question.
I wasn't there, but Dave suspects,
maybe Pete said something like,
is it possible that Robert Johnson got
so good because he's sold his soul to the
devil and son?
Son I think gave a kind of hesitant
answer that seemed like it left open that
possibility price said something
like, yeah, sure it's possible.
David says Pete takes that
non answer and runs with it.
Publishes an article where he
says, you wouldn't believe this,
but son House told me that Robert
Johnson sold his soul to the devil.
Pete. He was a writer, a stylist,
a bit of a liar quotes.
He himself even admitted that that
article was a bit over the top,
over the top or not. The story exploded,
got printed over and over
and books and magazines,
Compton and others talked about it at
concerts and over time it just became part
of the cannon.
The story that we like to tell about a
guy that we really know nothing about.
[inaudible]
been okay. I mean, this was not why
we decided to do this story. I mean,
the whole thought was that
it's gotta be something more going on
here than just a bad game of telephone
because the music does seem to
suggest that there is more going on.
I mean it does feel haunted and midway
through our reporting we did learn one
thing that suddenly made the
myth make a kind of sense,
like real sense, not just story sense.
Really. Yeah. Tell me that story.
Well, we heard it from a
guy named Mack McCormick.
I'm actually going to play you a,
him talking about it in a an old
documentary that we found. Okay.
And Mac is probably the expert on Robert
Johnson and in the 80s he tracked down
some of Robert Johnson's family that no
one had been able to locate and he came
back with a really different
story about the guy then,
at least I would have ever expected
did.
Robert Johnson was married in
1929 but he was quite young.
He was about 18 says Mac and he met a
girl named Virginia and he fell in love
when he married. He made one of the
important decisions in his life,
which was to live a conventional life.
They were going to live
on a farm, raise a family.
Up until then he'd been a kind of a
casual party musician and his wife,
Virginia, became pregnant.
She decided to go back to her family to
have the child he was going to join her.
But right before she was
due, Robert went off playing,
kind of snuck off to play a few
gigs before the baby was born.
And when he went to visit her, he
found that she died in childbirth
[inaudible]
and he was destroyed.
And he was faced with
this incredible community,
condemnation of what you've done to
Virginia because he was in Virginia's
childhood community at the time.
And they looked upon him as an itinerant
evil musician who was singing the devil
songs and she killed Virginia.
And he gradually became that person
that the community saw in mass.
So if Robert Johnson
was haunted by anything,
maybe it was grief
[inaudible]
oh, Amada.
Hmm.
So, so you, so if you had to
tell it, you'd say, so no,
he didn't go out and meet the devil.
He had this tragedy and the
tragedy changed him and it
changed you into a great
musician. That's what I would say.
[inaudible] [inaudible] um,
[inaudible]
and that's where our story might have
ended. Hello? Hello Mac. Yes. Hi,
this is Pat Walker.
But that story about Robert Johnson's
young wife dying in childbirth was so sad
and fascinating that we really wanted
to talk to the guy who found it.
My name is Mack McCormick. He's the
guy we just heard in the documentary.
But when we mentioned that story that
he told about Robert Johnson twice dying
in childbirth, he, uh, he
kind of cut us off. No,
let's not get into that. Why not? That's,
that's not something I've
converged confirmed satisfactorily.
What does that mean? I have, um,
doubts about the things I
said years ago specifically.
Like what? Uh, well, okay,
this is one Mack told us about a weird
encounter he'd had in New Orleans in New
Orleans.
I was told about a man named Robert
Johnson who was a blues musician and this
was years after, you know,
the Robert Johnson had died and I went
racing down the street to this address.
What would I got there? This man,
so this, they was Robert Johnson.
He was a blues singer, had been, but he
was not the man who made the records,
but he was somebody who at the time had
gone around imitating the records and
Mechs as it that moment
he started to wonder like,
is it possible that the stories I've
been connecting about Robert Johnson,
one particular Robert
Johnson, the Robert Johnson,
or actually about a collection
of different Robert Johnson's,
this is what you have to
apply our statistics here.
Robert's a pretty common first name and
Johnson's a pretty common last name.
So if you have a state with whatever
population, you've got to say,
there's this many Robert Johnson's, we
don't know how many, but Mac figures,
there's certainly more than
one and as Max doubt mounted,
he started to run into other problems.
Have you seen the death certificate?
I've seen reprints of it in books.
Have you seen a reprint of
the backside of it? No. Okay.
The backside says that he had come from
Tunica county to play Banjo at a country
dance, play Banjo,
but Johnson played the guitar and
to make matters more confusing,
the death certificate said that this
Robert Johnson died of syphilis,
not whiskey poisoning. This
has gotta be a different guy.
Mek wasn't entirely convinced until he
met this guy who had played with Robert
Johnson back in the day.
He and Robert Johnson jammed together a
little bit when Mac brought up Johnson
and the fact that he died in 1938 this
guy give him a funny look and said, no,
I,
I saw him in a Rodeo in 39 I believe it
was April or so in 39 a few years later,
the same thing happened with
another guy Mack was talking to.
He said that he'd seen
Johnson in Memphis April,
1941 and not too long after
that it happened again.
So it's things like that that,
that give you a hint that you might be
wrong and if you're wrong about whether
he died or not. How do you know
any of these other things that I believed?
Obviously when Mac told us this,
we were really disappointed.
Kind of kills the story,
although we do still have this song,
which is incredible. The 28 others,
maybe that's enough.
And if you think back to that moment in
Carnegie Hall where music was drifting
out of that audience for the first time,
we talked about that earlier
as an absence, but it's really,
it's not if it's all we got actually
it's everything. Okay.
Hmm.
But on the subject of Robert Johnson,
there's the book by writer Tom Graves.
It's called crossroads the life and
afterlife of Blues Legend Robert Johnson.
And thanks to Elijah Wald who wrote
escaping the delta. I don't know though,
the subtitle, DMSO, Robert Johnson,
the invention of the blues and Peter
Goralnick whose book on Robert Johnson's
quote searching for Robert Johnson.
There's a lot of people looking for
that guy. Yeah. And the truth is,
I should also just say that to close
this out is the person who put Robert
Johnson in my head and his music in my
head is a guy named dean ulcer. Sorta,
my first mentor in Radio, uh,
used to run a great program called the
next big thing. Big Heartfelt Bluesy,
ulcer. Um, Gentleman Ron, I'm Robert
Krulwich. Thanks for listening.